bonjour et bienvenue dans chroniques de
profs l'émission dans laquelle je vais
m'efforcer de vous faire comprendre
l'histoire cet immense oeuvre toujours
en cours d'écriture à travers moult
exemples blagues plus ou moins réussies
pour ce premier épisode je voudrais vous
parler d'un epic fail militaire que je
trouve très drôle et qui s'est passé au
14e siècle
malheureusement cet événement étant liée
à la guerre de cent ans je ne peux pas
vous le raconter sans résumé d'abord
cette guerre ses enjeux ses conséquences
terribles
tous les professeurs d'histoire vous
diront il est quasiment impossible de
résumer la guerre de cent ans en moins
de dix minutes
mais comme je ne suis pas techniquement
profs et que j'aime les défis allons-y
et c'est parti pour la guerre de cent
ans
oui enfin en réalité est là plutôt dur
et 116 angle c'est comme si je disais
que les jeux olympiques ont débuté à
oullins filloux que la guerre de six
jours a duré six jours
wait d'abord les causes et bien tout
commence avec la mort de charles iv le
bel qui est le fils de philippe le bel
dont on peut retenir qu'il est impliqué
dans le procès des templiers qui n'ont
pas brûlé en sli voilà c'est mieux
charles iv devient roi en 1322 à la
suite de son frère qui est mort sans
amitié et il meurt à son tour en 1328 le
roi est mort vive on sait pas trop qui
l'ont fait charles iv est mort sans
héritier mâle il avait bien laissé sa
femme enceinte avant de mourir mais
manque de bol c'est une fille qui est
née
je ne sais pas pourquoi on rechigne à
laisser pouvoir une femme ça m'échappe
bref en 1328 ces bordels et trois
personnes se dévouent bien pour
reprendre la couronne mais comme ils
sont très polis ils passent leur temps à
se refiler le bébé
non c'est toi qui va régner mais non je
ne suis pas dit non je déconne ils se
mettent sur la gueule
finalement on décide que ce sera
philippe de valois qui règnera je vous
préviens dans cette histoire on va
bouffer du chat et du philippe les deux
prénoms les plus donnés au 14ème siècle
on peut oublier le deuxième candidat en
apprenant qu'il sera pas roi il se
contente de dire reflets et puis ce même
par contre le troisième candidat dont je
n'ai pas encore parlé est un emploi un
rosbif 1 obladi oblada edouard iii
d'angleterre petit fils de philippe le
bel par sa mère et dans 3 et déçu
frustré trahi il se retranchait m en 9
ans pour préparer sa vengeance qu'à
l'essence
carrick et envies 337 c'est la guerre il
envoie un de ces archevêque à paris et
balance son gant au pied de philippe qui
se dit roi de france donc ça y est la
balance et son gant ok c'est lors des
affrontements des batailles navales des
pillages philippe de valois à plus de
bateaux et décide de s'en servir pour
imposer un blocus commercial entre
l'angleterre et la france comme la
fédération du commerce oui et vous savez
comment termine la fédération du
commerce dans star wars le blocus est
levé parce que les négos dira un peu
court on plaçait le générateur qui
alimente toute leur flotte juste dans
l'entrée de leur vaisseau principal
est-ce que les français peuvent faire
pire que ça oui c'est ça dont je voulais
vous parler
l'epic fail qui me fait tellement rire
bensid vais plutôt me faire pleurer
la bataille de l'écrivain lieu dans ce
qui est aujourd'hui la belgique une fois
hélas faute française et rassemblés face
au port prête à affronter les anglais
qui arrivent et comment les français
dont il se déployait pour prendre
l'aventage ils vont enchaîner tous les
bateaux les uns aux autres un mur de
bateaux sur bon my world
comment venir à bout de ce maire de batz
totalement immobilisé
vous ne passerez pas
oh
bon n'ont pas utilisé le feu à la place
les anglais ont couvert de flèches
l'ensemble des navires immobilisés et
sont montés à l'abordage pour massacrer
les français qui n'ont eu d'autre choix
que de se jeter à l'eau et tenter de
survivre en agitant leurs petites
cuisses de grenouilles
bilan 15 mille morts une flotte
française presque entièrement détruite
ils resteront les champions un bon
moment ces mangeurs de geler j'adore
l'angleterre ne me jugez pas bref suite
à cette victoire
edouard iii va enchaîner les victoires
ah les français il réussit à l'annexé
calais il aurait une complètement la
france parce que la guerre ça coûte cher
et en 1356 fort de la bataille de
poitiers il réussit à capturer l'aura de
france jean le bon ces cochons qui avait
succédé à philippe si vous suivez
toujours
il a gagné la première manche les
français payent une rançon et d'ordre
environ deux ans des recettes du pays de
quoi plomber leur pib et il perd environ
un tiers du territoire
quelques années plus tard le fils de
jean le bonbon sur le trône charles 5
lesage
il commence à reconquérir les terres
perdues par son papa et il y arrive tout
va bien alors à la durée quoi 30 ans
cette guerre je suis déçu on m'avait
vende mieux que ça que nenni car l'heure
est maintenant à la guerre civile
charles aussi ces malades est un peu fou
y'a qu'à voir son portrait des mots
dépressif pour en être persuadé
et c'est là qu'entre en scène les
bourguignons qui prennent assez vite
leur indépendance vis-à-vis de la
franchise assassin's leduc d'aureilhan
parce qu'il ne l'aimait pas et on devine
déjà une petite attirance envers les
anglais rien de sexuel même nom en 1415
la bataille d'azincourt bien plus
célèbre que la bataille d'une écluse
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure mais
pas plus glorieuse puisqu'avec un
rapport de force de 3 contre 1 des
français arrive va perdre lamentablement
ça serait londres entrer dans les
détails mais les anglais avaient de très
bon arc et les français de petits
chevaux qui pataugent dans la boue
c'est un carnage pour l'armée française
en raid 5 le roi d'angleterre ne fait
pas de prisonniers ils sont tous
exécutés des milliers de noble français
meurt on peut dire que dans la plupart
des familles nobles française quelqu'un
est mort à agencourt si toi aussi le
tournant c'est très mauvais coup le
petit anglais j'ai vu 13 chevalier maure
c'était sur wikipédia que ce soit exact
ou pas 13 contre 6000 ça fait mal après
ça les bourguignons rejoignent
franchement à côté anglais
et à la place dur est fait pareil je
fais ici une petite parenthèse sur les
bords gagnant parce qu'il faut pas
croire que ce sont juste des ducs
quelque part en france
non les morineau sont forts et sur
environ un siècle 15e ils font de ce
qu'on peut appeler l'état bourguignon
ils sont indépendants du royaume de
france ils font ce qu'ils aiment la
coface je ne suis pas un bon guignole
mais je suis du nord et sachez que les
formes au xvème siècle font également
partie de l'état bourguignon lille
compris j'en parle parce qu'ils jouent
un rôle très important en cette période
et vous savez sûrement déjà entendu
landon sans forcément savoir qu'ils
étaient philippe le hardi jean-sans-peur
philippe lebon charles le téméraire
après la mort de charles le téméraire le
duché de bourgogne repasse dans le
royaume de france mais avant ça il
représentait une sorte de force
d'opposition
un peu comme la grenouille qui voulait
se faire plus grosse que le bourguignon
jours par mois est sûrement dû à
l'occasion mais voilà pour la brève
présentation et si vous êtes tombé sous
le charme de cette famille sachez qu'il
existe une version de 2048 spécial
bourgogne for the win il ya des gens qui
font ce genre de choses sur internet
ok c'est moi qui l'ait fait mon mémoire
me rendait folle les bourguignons obsédé
jean-sans-peur transformer toi changeons
de sujet quelques années plus tard les
deux mois et demi henry 5 et charles 6
meur la même année ce qui fait que leurs
héritiers peuvent tous les deux
prétendre au trône de fer tunisair ce
qui fait que leur sel et yepes tous les
deux prétendre au trône de france et
celui ci aurait pu revenir aux anglais
sans intervention de la pucelle
non pas celle là puis scène jeanne d'arc
qui vient booster un peu le dauphin
charles de 7 ce qui lui permet de bouter
les anglais hors de france qui reçoit
des remerciements très chaleureux trop
chaleureux puisqu'il la livre aux
anglais et vous connaissez la suite
le conflit se termine lentement mais
sûrement après cet épisode les des
anglais rentrer chez eux un peu déçu
mais ne vous inquiétez pas ils
trouveront bien d'autres occasions de se
taper dessus on s'est levé à la boîte
sur nous
ce premier épisode des chroniques de la
prof est maintenant terminée j'espère
qu'il vous a plu et que vous avez appris
des choses à faire
n'hésitez pas à commenter à partager sur
les réseaux sociaux pour instruire nos
amis et à vous abonner puisque j'ai
encore des tas de choses à vous raconter
enfin j'ajouterai que je ne connais pas
tout surtout donc si vous avez des
corrections apportées n'hésitez pas su
personnel corrections apportées je
considérais comme un résumé de la guerre
de cent ans est parfait merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo et ne manquez pas
les prochaines
à bientôt